welcome back everyone to my round five
recap from Buell in this one I played
International Master Marco Materia who
is a pretty young player uh 13 or 14
years old and about a hundred points
higher rated than mean and coming into
this game I was expecting him to play D4
and he didn't surprise me with at least
the first move and we went into a
Queen's Gambit declined an after Knight
C3 we reached a very typical position
for Queen's Camp declined where black
has a lot of moves and over the years
I've played many different things from
this position uh there's Bishop E7
there's C6 there's A6 there's Bishop B4
there's C5 but the move I played is the
fifth most popular according to the
Masters database is Knight B to D7 and
this is known as a Barman variation and
it's a slightly tricky offbeat line
which can Branch out in a lot of
different directions and from here white
has a lot of different options to play
but my opponent chose to play Bishop F4
which is one of uh the main moves third
moves popular
and after Bishop to F4 I play another
bit of a sideline and I played the move
which I think is the most aggressive
option for black is Bishop to B4
and this resembles uh ragozan opening uh
the ragozen being Bishop B4 in this
position but after I played Bishop B4 on
move 5 it is basically a ragozian
sideline and there's a lot of ways that
white can come under pressure early in
the game he took on D5 and after I take
back the main move uh by far is Pond E3
for lights and I just want to show that
if I plays E3 the idea for black is to
play 94 not only pressuring the pinned
Knight on C3 but also preparing ideas of
G5 and if Bishop G3 then later H5 and H4
and
um it's a really fun opening and I've
put a lot of effort into preparing this
line and before the game I was reviewing
a lot of shark variations that converge
from this position
but uh this didn't happen because after
I played Pawn takes D5 he took his first
kind of extended think of the game and
he played a move which has only been
played once before in the Masters
database uh during the game I thought it
was probably a novelty but it's a very
rare move Pawn to G3 and this is not a
move that I've studied before but
I think it had a interesting idea of
just trying to avoid anything I could
have potentially prepared before the
game let me hide the notation to avoid
spoilers but G3 it is a little bit
unusual for this position because very
often
the light spray Bishop develops uh to D3
or E2 and G3 does not harmonize well
with the darksprayed bishop but it's
still a way to develop and of course
after Bishop G2 and castling light will
have a very safe King so at this point
I'm on my own I was trying to figure out
uh the best path forward and I continue
with the major idea in the position
Knight to E4 pressuring the knights he
plays Rook C1 and I did have the urge
here to play G5 in the style of lines
that I Was preparing but one of the
advantages of having the pawn on G3
rather than having committed to pawn E3
is White House will move Bishop D2 here
and I think this would just diffuse any
sort of pressure I have in the position
the Knight is no longer pinned white
threatening to take and I've committed
to G5 weakening my king side so I chose
not to go for this but rather just try
and be solid and I played the move Pawn
Z6 I do want to note that another
candidate move was Knight D F6 but this
would just blunder due to Queen A4 check
so C6 has a idea of not only solidifying
the center but preventing Queen A4
tactics and potentially preparing Knight
to F6
so going forward he plays Bishop G2 I
Castle he castles and now that the
Knight is no longer pinned uh White is
maybe threatening to take so I decide to
take first on C3 he takes back and I
play Bishop to A5 so the tension has
relieved itself a little bit and we have
a pretty fresh middle game position
which I think for both of us was
unfamiliar territory because it's a
slightly strange setup for whites but at
the same time black is a little bit
underdeveloped and I have to figure out
how to activate my knight and my Bishop
uh so here he plays Queen to D3 kind of
a nice centralizing move I play rookie 8
which I thought is just the most
flexible I know my Rook wants to be on
the half open volume
and then he plays the move Knight to D2
which I think is a nice move
given the setup for white with the
bishop on G2 it's no longer blocked in
by the knights and Knight D2 has idea of
potentially preparing E4 or C4 which are
basically the two major Pawn breaks for
whites and it's not easy for me to stop
either one so I just continue with um
developing I play Knight F6 and then he
plays Pawn to F3 so he's making his
intentions very clear and he wants to
play E4 and I wasn't actually expecting
F3
until it came on the board and then I
realize it's very hard to stop
E4 from coming because white has one two
three four things supporting E4 I only
have three things contesting the square
so it seems like it's a guarantee that
white will get this move in and then
maybe dominate the the center with the
pawns so I took a bit of the think here
and I came up with an interesting idea
to try and prevent Pawnee 4 from
happening I started with Knight 2 H5
and I was trying to make it so E4 is not
so attractive for white and if white
plays E4 in this position I'd be happy
to take after takes back uh four pawns
weak the bishop is kind of dumb on G2 so
for this reason he plays Bishop to E3
and even though it looks like an ugly
Square for the bishop white is planning
to play Bishop F2 and still eventually
Pawn E4 and
um yeah even though White's pieces look
awkward uh there's a lot of potential
energy for lights where if I give white
a few free moves then I could come under
just major fire in the middle game
so I wanted to do something quick and
the move I played was I think a very
ambitious move and when I played it I
was actually pretty happy with it is
Pawn to F5 not only fighting for the E4
square but having ideas of eventually
playing Pawn F4 and what ended up
happening after he played rookie one I
played Bishop E6 he played Bishop F2
preparing pong E4 I'm pretty quick to
get in this move Pawn F4 and the benefit
of having the pawn on F4 is I make it so
that if he plays E4 I take onpassan and
he's not getting this big Pawn Center
and meanwhile if he plays Pawn takes F4
I'm very happy to get the knight in
hitting the queen and the bishop
so I was happy with this idea but he
seemed pretty unfazed and he played E4
anyway going for central control
and I take on passant he takes back with
rook and I play Queen to D7 in hindsight
maybe um maybe I shouldn't have played
Queen D7 I played this move because I
wanted to prepare Bishop F5 and my other
candidate move was Bishop F7 but I
didn't want to allow the bishop to come
to to H3 on just a better diagonal so I
thought Queen D7 is a more useful kind
of proprietory move but the drawback of
this move is it walks into
potential Knight C5 attacks and my
opponent very quickly plays Knight B3
hitting the bishop and preparing Knight
C5 now I was ready for this I played
Bishop to B6 so if Knight C5 happens I
just take
and something very similar did happen
after rookie one I played Knight F6 and
then he goes for Knight C5 and the
position transforms a bit I take and he
takes and we reach a position where I've
conceded the bishop hair uh White does
have the two Bishops and even though
they're not so impressive right now uh
there's a lot of potential for them to
become strong later on so for this
reason I was very much inclined to try
and trade off light squared Bishops and
get a situation where it's this Knight
versus this bishop
but I made a just complete misjudgment
and complete oversight with my next move
I ended up playing Bishop to H3 which I
think is the first big mistake of the
game uh now actually after the game I
called into my twitch stream because
Jonathan trance was doing commentary and
he told me that there was a really cool
idea for black in this position that is
very hard to see
and I think it's a really instructive
positional exercise so for anyone
watching that wants to treat this
position as a exercise and trying to
find the best move for black feel free
to pause the video this is black to move
and just try and find
um a better move than what I played
Bishop H3 so the move that Jonathan told
me is actually very strong is Pawn to D4
and this did not even cross my mind
during the game it looks ridiculous to
help white undouble the C pawns but the
point is it's actually a very useful
trade because after let's say white
takes with the pawn black can take on A2
and not only is black getting an outside
pass a pawn which can be very useful
long term in the end game but blocks
also cleared the D5 Square for the
bishop or potentially the knights and
this would actually be a really good
positional transformation because if
white is left with these two pawns on
the dark squares then the dark Spirit
Bishop is not at all a dangerous piece
and now if we compare this to what
happened in the game the D4 Square was
available for the bishop and I didn't
have the D5 Square for my knight so when
I played Bishop H3 he found a really
strong response which I overlooked he
took I took and he played the move here
which
has actually been a recurring theme in a
lot of my games and it's a term that I
didn't even know how to name until again
watching Jonathan's commentary uh
Jonathan calls us a co-linear move
and there's been a few examples of this
in my previous games but a co-linear
move is basically when you move on the
same line as an opponent's piece but you
don't take the piece
and in this case our Rooks are staring
at each other and rather than white
taking on e8s white plays the move Rook
E7
stopping one square short of the trade
and rookie seven was well I overlooked
when I played Bishop H3 and I realized
at this moment that black is under
serious pressure given that my seventh
rank is very vulnerable mainly the B7
Pawn is not so easy to defend without
making a big concession so what I did
here was take once on E7 and after takes
back I played the move Pawn to B6 and
this turned out to be another major
mistake because I overlooked White's
next move which turns out to be
incredibly strong and my opponent found
it relatively quickly the queen to A6
and once this came on the board I
realized that uh yeah the position is
actually just very bad even though it
looks like maybe I have some counter
play on the king side White's King side
setup is incredibly solid that three
Pawn restricts my knight and meanwhile
there is just a ton of pressure with my
A7 Pawn now attacked not to mention
ideas of Queen B7 hitting my rook and
the G7 Pawn as well
and the move I wanted to play here was B
take C5 and I was really trying to make
this work in my calculations but I
didn't end up going for it because after
Queen B7 Rook E8 Rook takes G7 it just
seemed really bad to lose the G7 Pawn
even though maybe this position is still
playable I opted for a different line I
played Queen C8 which basically just
loses a pawn after it takes takes and
takes but after B5 I still had hope in
trying to survive this position given
that White's pawns are a bit fixed on
the C file and light can never at least
easily make a past a pawn given that my
Pawn is controlling A4 but the problem
with this position for black is white
has much Superior pieces the bishop and
The Rook are gonna be so much better
than my knight in Rook and for the next
many moves I think uh I think it's very
instructive even though it's very
painful for the black side white just
keeps improving starting with Bishop D4
and I was essentially forced to just
wait around for my inevitable Doom I put
my Rook on E6 but after G4 there's
really no active plan for black in the
position I move my king lights improves
a rook I drop back with the Knights he
pins me I move up with the King and then
he keeps expanding on the king side and
it's a very simple plan for whites given
that there's a three on two majority and
White's plan is just to keep pushing on
the king side while I just have to wait
and after King E7 Rook 8 I keep waiting
the light keeps making kind of gradual
progress and after King G3 Knight C7
Rook A7 I'm still very much down I
played rookie seven and after he played
F4 we passed move 40 this is move 41 and
I took a long time here trying to just
see if there's any last chance in the
position but I think at this point it's
just pretty hopeless and after maybe 20
to 30 minutes of thinking I played the
move Pawn to G6 and my opponent just
basically bulldozed me on the king side
he played Pawn F5 after it takes takes
King Y8 my one last trick in the
position was praying for King A4 which
at first looks like a natural move but
this would actually just plunder away
the game because there's 96 and I would
win The Rook but my opponent was tackly
alerts he did not play King F4 he played
the much stronger Bishop F6 and this
forces simplification so I have to stay
defending the knights and after Bishop
E5
we eventually simplify into a King Pawn
ending now I didn't resign because
there's still one last trick in the
position which I'll go ahead and show
after King F4 King D7 King E5 King E7 my
one hope was that white would play F6
King f8 King E6 after which B4 take D4
I'm breaking through in the center
although now that I'm realizing it I
think this is still losing for black
because here here here here
and even though I queen first light is
just mating in the end so even my one
last trick did not work but he didn't
even allow it because he played A3 in
this position and I resigned after what
was a pretty tough game a very painful
ending but uh yeah I think I was very
much punished for the mistakes I made in
the later middle game and I do want to
give big kudos to my opponents if you
check this game with the engine I can go
ahead and uh and click the button
let me enable engine analysis
and we do see that my opponent played
very cleanly his one inaccuracy came
with this G3 move which I think was
actually a smart opening choice to avoid
my venomous preparation
but uh yeah I can't be too upset gotta
take the lesson as it comes and tomorrow
is a rest day so there's not going to be
a classical game tomorrow but there will
be a blitz tournament and I do plan to
film all my games from the blitz so stay
tuned for some Blitz content I probably
won't have time to post any Blitz videos
until after the tournament but the next
classical game will be 2 p.m on Sunday
uh 2 p.m Beal time so do stay tuned
there are five more rounds I'm two and a
half out of five so hopefully I can get
back on a plus score and also stay tuned
for live commentary with Jonathan
schrance on my twitch Channel twitch.tv
I am Rosen and also stay tuned for more
Recaps I'll see you guys soon